okay first things first yes ma'am
yes ma'am hallelujah and Sam Tyra I saw
this and literally I I got goose bumps I
was like I couldn't love you more then
seeing this right now thank you
proud of this are you I'm really really
proud yeah it's kind of surreal and the
cover-up and everything for the first
time today and I was like what and my
favorite color my favorite colors yellow
this little you know why it's little why
because I was a 25 pounds 30 pounds
heavier than the cover 22 years ago
really yeah and so the secret is I mean
you gain a little this swimsuit goes
smaller really people think it's the
opposite yeah cuz I'm looking for a
one-piece for the first time Missy no no
no because you're thicker yeah then you
go smaller oh yes no matter the body
type really it's in whatever if you just
feel like you just a little bit a lot of
Pizza the smaller cuz today we're in
this this world of like body acceptance
and celebration and when that swimsuit
is smaller the gush and stuff just looks
so luscious as opposed to stuffing it in
this like big bikini that you just know
let it go let that stomach flow let the
booty jiggle let those cellulite
whatever you have dental floss it the
bigger you are but women at home are
gonna say but you're Tyra oh no no no I
know this is the rule I also give tips
to people of how to make themselves
better and I'm telling you that is well
can I can I just read a couple things to
you because I just saw these I was
looking because people of course have
been posted this cover everywhere really
and folks around the country are going
crazy I just looked on on Instagram and
the first thing was who told her to step
on our necks like this and then the next
one was she looks great she they say a
real body who would have thought they
still existed oh and she want to act
like her body's not snatch Tyra really
out here redefining beauty and showing
y'all what a real woman looks like you
know but it's true because you were
saying you're you're a few pounds
heavier in this photo but I think you
look so sexy and so happy and so
confident what do you want to tell us
about how to love ourselves and love our
bodies cuz you've been doing that
forever but now you're in a new phase
I'm in a new phase you know I have a new
body I I will be honest I do know how to
lose weight I know what to eat I have
one of the best nutritionists in the
world that is like my homegirl and when
I have to pull it together to play Eve
hi I'm even I'm your special friend I
call her and we pull it together and
when I was like okay I'm gonna shoot si
again I was like okay I'm gonna pull it
together I'm gonna get my body the same
exact size from 22 years ago and I
started and I was so focused and then I
went to my mom's house and there was
some Cheetos in the in the and I just
had the Cheetos and then that was like
the gateway in and then I was like after
Cheetos you have to have an ice-cream
party so my mom my son and I went to the
grocery store we had strawberry coffee
ice cream we had green tea ice cream
chocolate but no a spread three spoons
and just kind of played musical ice
cream and then that was even deeper and
then from there I just I just lost my
mind so shooting in the Bahamas grits
with shrimp every morning bread and
butter pancakes I don't know what
happened and I I don't think it was just
oh I'm losing control I think I was like
you know what let me just celebrate what
I am now and just be real because I'm
constantly telling people beauty and all
sizes beauty and all ages but hey I'm
sure I look like my old self right so I
think subconsciously was like nah let's
kind of show them what's up now however
I teach modeling for years and years so
I know how to pose I know what to do I
notice take the booty out and push the
face
there's tricks that I know how to do to
look more in shape than I am but she'll
see the video footage from SI roll it
right now
[Music]
you'll see jiggle-jiggle that i can't
control because it's motion camera was
there any part of you though that said
what if people don't love the way I look
yeah I you know the the internet
particularly social media is the most
beautiful thing in the world and the
meanest thing in the world and so I know
there's gonna be people putting pictures
next to each other going oh she's
thicker now or she's this she's that or
sit your old ass down I know that's
gonna happen but I didn't do this for
them actually I do do it for them mm-hmm
I did do it for them because the people
that are saying that actually have a
negativity associated with themselves
with body with age the person that is
telling somebody sit your old ass down
it's terrified of aging yes it's
actually I didn't think of it that way
if Tyra is not y'all women crush
Wednesday just go back to bed get on
Thursday cuz this is ridiculous yeah
would Tyra of 2019 tell Tyra of 1997 I
would say Tyra and no you're really
really really driven but sit your ass
down
that's your own ass about the old ass
but it's okay ass in the future ass sit
down take some time go to the spa chill
at the movies with your friends don't
just run in and out you know success is
important but also the balance of just
taking it all in
don't just do the fashion just don't
just do the photoshoot on the beach and
then go run in the hotel room and watch
TV go take a walk meet some locals I
didn't do that it was 1997 Tyra was a
little uptight
she was uptight she was on a mission but
I guess I wouldn't be talking to you she
wasn't uptight right good 1997 Tyra got
us right here
exactly why did you decide 13 years
later to come out of retirement I
decided to come out of retirement
because I always say there's no such
thing as cookie cutter beauty to me I'm
gonna bust those beauty walls down right
but I retired from modeling because I
didn't want to age out of the system I
wanted to say no to the modeling
industry and goodbye before they kicked
me out because of age yet Here I am
saying beauty at all ages so to me it
wasn't authentic anymore I still wanted
to be honest and say that is why I
retired it wasn't like oh I had a talk
show don't know any taken seriously yes
that was part of it but it was I need to
get out of here before y'all kicked me
out so I wanted to be authentic that way
and so I came out of retirement 45 years
old I'm modeling again speaking of the
definition of beauty
Halima Aden that's the first Somali
American woman in a full bikini you were
the first african-american woman to
grace the cover this year you have the
first african-american and woman to
shoot you for the cover how important is
that to be a part of these
history-making events yes in this end
I'm obsessed with first yes I am
obsessed with first I was obsessed with
it for myself and I'm obsessed with
first for everyone I feel like my
mission in life is to open doors for
other people and to to get them in plate
to places that they probably couldn't do
on their own I think we all need a
little help my mama was my boost and I
hope to be that for so many people so I
spoke to em Jay the editor of the Sports
Illustrated edition and I said swimsuit
edition and I said um MJ
you guys changed my life 23 years ago
you put me on that cover and then the
next year you put me on again over night
it changed my life and gave me such a
powerful platform and now I want to
change somebody's life I want us to find
an african-american female photographer
and so she started on her side I started
and she says Tyra you know what this is
ridiculous because why am i searching
this hard this is ridiculous so then I
went to the Internet and I went to
social media and I was googling and
searching and clicking and instagramming
and came upon Loretta Houston on
Instagram on Instagram from her
Instagram I created a Pinterest board of
her pictures and two other photographers
by the way this was America's Next Top
Model
the tot of three there were three really
strong female african-american
photographers and I'm like why are they
not stars they're there so their social
media looks like they should be shooting
for si for Vogue but why are they still
saying on their websites for headshots
call me and I'm like oh what's going on
so I created three printers boards si
editor miss MJ chose Loretta and she was
my secret favorite and her life was
changed and onset she's shooting me in
the Bahamas we actually did not tell her
we did not tell her Etta that I chose
her so because we didn't want to rock it
too much and make her too nervous it's
already a lot of responsibility so she's
shooting me did not know I chose her but
then all of a sudden she just walks away
from the camera and starts crying yeah
it was like a moment of like and I was
like I had all this makeup on my face I
had to hold it together and I was I mean
think about that though I mean you
really when we talk about we want to
make our little corner of the world
better and do something for someone else
I mean you really change somebody's life
yeah okay seriously that's I mean that's
a feat in itself that's the secret to
the secret to joining upstairs as you
inhale really hard and it like sucks
what memories did you have of the first
time when you were back shooting or even
the second time I guess when you were
back shooting you know this time it's
interesting because my cover from 1997
the polka dot bikini on the beach was in
the pomace and this cover in the yellow
bikini is in the Bahamas nice so we were
all kind of freaking out about that I
wonder like because we know you as Tyra
but I understand from now on we need no
us banks banks with a neck with vnx but
just my model name okay oh yeah you know
how models have like interesting names
different names like Twiggy you know she
wasn't born Twiggy I was born Tyra Banks
KS yeah but yeah I why banks with the
next yeah banks for the next because I
want me coming out of retirement to be
bigger than me and for me to represent
women to say you know enough of this
cookie cutter thing as much as we
progressed with Beauty there's still a
long way to go in terms of opening up
the door and redefining what it means
and so that X stands for X what you
heard about what Beauty means we are
making a new rule that so many more
people can fit into this beauty box bust
the box open well I wonder because I
remember back when you had your talk
show and you came out and you did the
swimsuit and you were so emotional about
that because you were hurt by what
people were saying now you're
celebrating those curves how is your
relationship with your body yeah change
I go I'm human yeah I still don't love
to cellulite on my butt I still know how
to twist and turn even during this
photoshoot to make sure you don't see
the dimples in my booty so I'm still you
know I still have that I just don't
linger there and I celebrate the things
that I that are things that I'm proud of
I don't like that my calves are too
skinny I don't like that I have flat
feet I don't like that my hands or look
twenty years older than a face you know
you know there's just things that I
don't like but I just don't dwell there
but I'm also very honest and and say I
don't like it but it's not the end of
the world it's not the end of the world
because you know you out here just fine
and also I just have learned how to
conquer that and how to honestly
strategically not let you see those
things and that is one of my favorite
things to do is to teach women how to do
that which cover are you more excited to
show York so 1997 or the 2019 2019 he
was there and the Bahamas was he York
was there my mama was there so you know
he remembers the Bahamas he doesn't
really understand why mommy was there
but showing him this picture and guess
what York's favorite color is yellow
just like his mama so I think he'll be
four so he doesn't get it yet that his
mother is one of the most famous
supermodels no idea speaking of your
mother because I do love miss Carolyn
Mother's Day is coming up the most like
I guess useful or important piece of
advice that she's given you the most
important advice that my mother has
given me is look to the other side when
things are hard and you just feel like
you just can't get through it
imagine 30 days from now imagine six
months from now imagine a year you're
not gonna be crying about this so if you
can see the future and understand that
this is a temporary situation it helps
you get through as it worked it works
yeah it makes me know this is not this
is not permanent and it also helps me to
strategize my way out of this situation
do you have big plans for this this
weekend or just York have big plans do
you know you know what I Mother's Day is
so weird now because I'm a mom yeah so
I'm like wait mom are you are you taking
me to brunch am I taking you
like I'm so honestly confused and I'm
like so weird like texting or like mom
what are we doing wait am I supposed to
surprise you but I'm a mom
that's very confused yeah yes oh you
don't know you know I was a flow type of
day no but in December you said you were
leaving America
Got Talent because you had some huge
projects on the horizon is model and one
of them yes model and is okay yes I mean
I have my production company we're
producing a lot of TV film amazing
things but mono land is no joke
it is a startup I have any Questers I am
the founder of this thing you know we
are starting three businesses an
experienced restaurant kind of food
whole thing and a retail destination and
so that's three businesses one founder
you can imagine as I create so I have to
hire strong team members have them ask
cast team and continuing to grow it
takes a lot when can we expect cycle 25
of America's Next Top Model you know I
have an email in my inbox right now that
somebody is like this needs to happen
what are you doing let's meet when you
finish this Sports Illustrated swimsuit
or I have been dealing with somebody
that's like I want to make this happen
I want all stars do you do you want 25
all stars I wanted okay so can you give
me three that you really want there I'll
see if I can get them okay well I would
love Eva I don't know if she could okay
I would love to Cara okay I don't know
if she could but I would love to car and
then let me thank Jade there's a couple
I think she was season two season one or
two and I don't think she won but she
was oh God Chandi no I remember Sadie's
it's the second girl now I can't
remember her name short black hair short
cut and I just loved her Elise Elise
Sewell first season at least yeah at
least runner I would like though yes she
was the runner right I'm gonna try to
find her Elise just saying do you hear
that I was looking for you are you a
doctor
are you model what are you doing these
days cuz she wanted to be a doctor
Eva I know you're a housewife a Real
Housewife of Atlanta honey but you know
mama Tyra helped to make that happen and
you know that so come on back home to
Cara
Michelle want you I want you
well I just heard even given you mad
Prime oh really the other day in an
interview about how you completely
changed her life I mean of and how she
wouldn't be who she is today without
your advice your guidance and the show
most definitely how by the way how is
York does he does he want to do modeling
does he know how to pose do you catch
him
why me he probably wouldn't know me he
doesn't know what modeling you in him um
you know it's so funny
um I sometimes put his hair in a
ponytail and one day I was like can
mommy put your hair in a ponytail today
he said no mommy I don't want to be
beautiful beautiful today mommy yes and
it's so funny because York is um
naturally extremely photogenic extremely
the jeans and you have no idea I don't
like to share him on social media I'm
extremely private sometimes I get a shot
and I'm like oh the kids would go wild
see this picture and I just you know the
folks out there we call this a thirst
trap what does that mean when they see
this just thirsty I'm sure not miss
Carolyn not York do you know what I'm
talking about
I'm not we listen yeah but I don't talk
about you know that's okay there you
happy I want to go down memory lane with
you real quick oh my gosh yeah
I'm so happy
that is crazy because I don't remember
it that girl had no idea I think I was
in another world experiencing that I
only remember arriving to the party with
my parents and then crying like a baby
my journalists were asking me questions
isn't that interesting that that moment
was so big that I don't mean seriously
she didn't know she had the world in
front of her and it always and I was so
young I'm like who is that that's the
tire we fell in love with though that
ponytailed bouncy bounce
tire we love you someone thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]